you went to China you got you're
traveling a lot but you were in China
I've never been to China tell me what
that's like okay let me just tell you
because you're like nineteen feet tall
right you and I my makeup artist and I
went and she has burgundy hair we were
the only two black people in China and
it was like Brad and Angelina we're at
the great wall and it's great because
it's really long right right that's
what's called the Great Wall yeah
greatly long and I'm not kidding people
were just the double takes walk bumping
into each other like it was like a
domino effect you know Val I've seen
enough at the Great Wall if we keep
going people are gonna die yeah right
here they were that freaked out they
were they weren't freaked out they're
the nicest people but it was literally
like and they're still walking and then
bumping into the next person it's like
this is amazing it was a lawyer there
was yeah it was hilarious so they just
weren't so that you're not seeing a lot
there's not a lot of black people
walking around in China's way yeah I
felt great when I was a little kid my
dad had he's you know scientists and he
took me on down to South America and I
had bright orange hair q dead teeth in
my front and a bright freckles and my
mom gave me a Madras jacket just before
I went and he took me from city to city
and everywhere I went people would come
up and just touch my face and a hair
like I had just come from the circus so
weird it's so true I have to tell you it
was like wow this is kind of I guess wow
this is fascinating but they were like
the nicest people it was hilarious
though I was a hit in China you were
here yeah in the red red band society
produced by Steven Spielberg you were
nervous to meet him I wasn't nervous to
meet him I met him when we were doing
the help it well I kind of I did meet
him eventually I worked up the nerve but
you know how you think you're like
across the room and you're looking and
luring and I'm gonna work if I'm gonna
go say hello now but apparently I was
like I'm gonna go say hello now I'm
gonna say I'm doing it I'm doing it that
my friend came over she's like what is
happening what's going on with the eyes
I'm like what are you talking about you
look like a crazy person you were
staring at Spielberg I'm gonna
I'm gonna go say hello right I'm working
I'm doing it I'm going right now right
now and yeah that looks almost like
you're going to attack him that's the
vibe you're putting out I kind of did I
kind of you know grabbed him in a bear
hug because you think you know people
because they you know be around them I
did I was like hello how are you I love
you so much god I did it
did you we did you act that way cuz I
know when you first met Oprah I've heard
that you were very excited what did you
do Oprah I just I get real excited i I
did the same thing and of course I sweat
profusely because I'm I'm a nervous
wreck and Oprah has that calming voice
and she was terrified but it was how are
you we are okay we were great it's so
nice to me and I'm like oh my god I'm
terrifying Oprah got to calm it down
calm it down bring it down
Spencer bring it down she has that
apaches thing she can calm like if she
was in a wolf attack she would just
start talking to the walls and they were
going
you